why is zero factorial 1 okay because it
does seem to defy the idea all it's you
multiply down until you get down to
whatever one right and then you stop
right now I'm going to argue for this
the same way I would argue a very sort
of reverse or not love that I would I do
this how do you argue that because
you'll take it to be true right but it's
the same problem when you say on a
square but we define powers as you
multiply this number by itself that
number of times and that makes sense to
you but the definition breaks down the
u7 definition breaks down when you go to
cases like this so how do you argue it
or do you just accept it and don't think
about it all right people let's play a
game okay no it's still with a number
shall we
okay let's go on to power 1 - 2 squared
4 2 cubed ok you can start to see what's
going on right we don't need to people
who spent time on their phones recently
north east
now now you're listed doing it forward
aren't you you do it forward and the
numbers get bigger okay but just as
equally you can go backwards and the
numbers get smaller do they're not as
you your power decreases you divide by
two and then you divide by two and you
divide by two and when you get to here
we have no reason to think that the
pattern changes right so this pattern
becomes this and so we divide by two and
you get this and you keep on going and
it keeps making sense okay now therefore
can you argue for me why is your
factorial is what tell me what 1
factorial is 1 2 factorial 2 3 factorial
4 factorial okay so this time how do I
go backwards I divided by 4 and I
divided by 3 then I divided by 2
now bullet can I just say can I just say
um the reason why I bet a big deal that
this is because see this is what makes
maths it's what makes most interesting
to me
you see Matz is um it's an imagined
world that's the point of it right like
I learn maths can be used to do stuff
and that's that's nice okay
but um the point is that Oh
actually I'll come back to that in a
second the point is that it doesn't
matter if it can be used for something
or not the the point is that it has a
consistent system of rules that's
meaningful okay here's the amazing thing
right um there was a guy there's a guy a
French guy and his day was for you okay
and he was the guy who we earned he
discovered this order ago I have a look
at this for a second what is this ah
yeah language for this this is a wave
function now you don't know what wave
function is not a do I just drew it okay
but amazing thing about this this is
what I'm this is what Fourier proved
okay is that this wave function can be
made up of can be composed of just take
a whole bunch of sine functions right
the whole variety of them some of them
will be big right some of them will be
small so you have to change let's say
you have to change this coefficient on
the front and you change the frequency
okay
and if you add enough of them to get up
okay and so on you can make you can make
anything anything you can even make
weird looking things like this you like
I can make a function like that it's a
wave function I know it doesn't look
like it
it's got straight lines and what's with
that okay if you add up enough wave
functions different ones like this okay
like this one you can give us a else now
here's the interesting thing what was
for yeah after he just thought this was
kind of cool it was like this is
interesting right I wonder if you can do
that and he gave it to go and it came
okay uh he was not at all thinking about
practical applications right he was not
thinking about you know a world of
electric communications which uses this
routinely in order to you know how does
this thing know to convert weird stuff
which is in the air into sounds sounds
right how does it do that answer using
these but for you I wasn't thinking of
those here's just like cool let's just
see what happens right and the
application came later almost every
field of mass you know complex numbers
like why are we doing that for they come
up all the time for engineers but that's
not what the people who were thinking
about them we're thinking they're just
like it's cool zero factorial equals one
it does make sense just like southern
power of zero is one